what's up Bishop boy Superstar pride and
we're not rocking on the bootleg kill
podcast
bootle cap show special guest in here he
got a crazy record right now painting
pictures Superstar pride in the building
what's going on bro man let's probably
kill you skirt I can't complain brother
so you're from what part of Mississippi
are you from
where's uh the saw the baby growing up
move to Batesville Mississippi which is
uh
makeup Panola County and it's one more
City in the Como Mississippi come over
basement and started they make up
another country Okay so
give me the breakdown because you when I
think of Mississippi I think of like
Jackson Mississippi
and I think of the KKK exactly
there's a movie growing up called
burning Mississippi that was like all
about the KKK and I always just assumed
Mississippi is like the most racist
place on the planet is it that bad yeah
yeah it's bad it's dead bad damn I ain't
gonna owe you it's that bad
it ain't it ain't to the point The Wiz
hanging and [__] no more right but it's
it's still like I hang your black ass
don't just say that no but you can feel
it okay Jesus
um how long you been making music man
I made my first song I was six I started
record around
um team and then I never dropped until I
was 17. how do you know
um
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
that old all right he's hell yeah old
um no it's great so you you kind of
started taking it serious when you were
17. because that'd be the first time you
actually put some [__] out yeah yeah
that one I actually said I want to go on
here and push you through the world and
I stayed consistent from from then on to
up into this point and now you got a top
100 record on Billboard
crazy crazy what was the thing that like
uh do you know kind of like what was the
moment or two that kind of really popped
This Record off where you kind of
noticed it to like really kind of like
take off yeah
it's very went crazy when I put it on
Tick Tock I put it on Tick Tock and it
went from
3 000 views to
to 10 000 version 10 to 50 to 102. you
know and it was it was just out it went
from Tick Tock to YouTube that's when it
got real you feel me I watched my
subscribers started going up but the
first time I seen it I made it home from
working at the um car shop I was working
at a car shop at the time
when I had post a video I was going
through a lot you know what I'm saying
so I had ended up taking that pain and
just putting into what I was gonna do
like I took that and dropped that music
and now I took the pain from dropping
the mirrors you can put it in there
pushing it yeah without no money though
so I had to find a way without no money
and for you it was going to tick tock
making like content that no no the crazy
part is if I try everything like I did I
build up every platform like I did the
Facebook the Instagram the Twitter the
Audiomack you know what I'm saying doing
my main three four and I had YouTube on
working on right but I never could get
this junk to go crazy you feel me like I
wanted them like they I posted on them
and them drinks I get like 10K you know
eight you know what I'm saying a 20
bottles right now like some [__] like
that but then I need some [__] like the
one features them two hundreds I needed
some [__] and I put it on I made The
Tick Tock February 1st
just to um get the channel started I had
posted up I posted the old trailer and
the update of my haircut because I had
chopped it down
and then I was like I'm gonna let them
see the update and we'll bring back
the original video from like three or
four months so
I seen what they messed with it the new
haircut it went like 30 40
000.
and now yeah so when I posted oh no no
and the way that I I post new videos and
waited like two weeks later then I
approached the first old video with the
um live performance and then the gym
went from
I made it home from working all day
because I did it randomly I was just
random road we went stroke it apart
threw it on two charges probably right
Threw It on Tick Tock kept going through
the day made it home at night
well you know you're crazy the video
your video got like 250 thousand I'm not
for real went back to sleep you know
what I'm saying reason I bet you see I
went to sleep right you know what I'm
saying so boom went to sleep
woke up it was at like 1.2 1.3 million
then I was like this I was like this
this got to be this is crazy this this
ain't real you're right that's what I'm
thinking so I'm like nah let me make
sure it's real let me go get another
piece of the video and post it too you
feel me when I posted the videos in
between wait a couple days now post that
one yeah
when I posted
it went from eight o'clock to 12 o'clock
it went to like
2.3 million on tick tock on Tick Tock
Jesus and from four hours
I gave it four hours just to see what it
would do right from eight to noon it
would hit 2.2 2.3 that's crazy yeah I
didn't even really I had to I'm looking
for who Wants in the car I need to get
somebody
who can work these who need to do this
somebody need to get this so I I
actually got out I lived in there alone
when it went crazy I'm like I stopped
looking at them and I'm like bro it's
gone yeah you feel me like I know you
gotta get put the team together I need
to find who's going to put it yeah and
then who got to put it out I want the
world right
yo what were you doing at the car shop
like what was your job man my uncle got
a costume Motors so you were like a
mechanic yeah so what was CVS
can you see that
you so you know your way around like an
engine
uh could you change your own oil I could
tell you my own oil I can change my own
oil I just ain't gonna work on nobody
else
chasing just you know my own oil and
brakes let's see you can do brakes and
oil let's eat yeah I don't do it for me
but if I'm doing some work
I got a little knowledge
I'm curious like working in a car shop
in 2023 does most of the business that
comes in people who had the catalytic
converter stolen and you have to put new
ones in I ain't doing none of that no
I'm saying because the catalytic
converters just get jacked everywhere so
I'm assuming if you're a car shop that's
where they come they gotta go get a new
one that's what I'm saying this shop I
work in there they strictly focus on
building Motors like they they build
Motors man they literally from scratch
from scratch it's just a block anybody
here they putting all they don't know
I'm too much been in Motors they ain't
touching nothing they don't do no breaks
no oil none of that they ain't doing
nothing it's my uncle so he do Straight
personally he's building up crazy
engines crazy engine that they do street
racing down oh [__] so it's real like
there was the shot with that we had they
got the faster car no no so what is the
fastest car down there
bundle baby
what kind of car is it Malibu
what kind of engines in that though if
it's it's got to be like what like a
I'm gonna be real down you know people
down there you don't I don't think
they'd be telling you about dick
don't don't tell you about that don't
they ain't gonna tell you what's under
that Hood At what point in time do you
quit the job with your uncle and you say
hey Uncle I gotta I gotta go oh I was
done I mean like like a week or two I
was still in the shop I'm looking at the
numbers going crazy still and you're
still working still showing up to work
getting your breath you're getting to
work you know what I'm saying geez I'm
really just you know what I'm saying
still enjoying the moment of living
so therefore I just did what I did
and I was sitting in the car with this
guy right here I'm into demo fantastic
send me that video of the bundle baby
he worked for my own he working
So eventually I mean obviously you got
kind of you gotta step away you gotta go
push the music right uh I'm gonna tell
you I would like [__] that [__]
I'm just getting the music understand me
see me work in the shop I was like [__]
I'm just getting on the music and let
them work that [__] on do what they do
it you're gonna double up have the job
you just had a job yeah and get them
there I'm gonna learn this [__] why why
they do this [__] and she got to a point
where I'm walking around that [__] and
every day I'm I'm coming in the shop the
numbers on the internet getting crazy
right you feel me so
they like one day like oh yeah he cool
then you seeing they like oh [__] what's
up what's up bro yeah then they go from
what's up brother
Superstar you know what I mean so then
when everybody started noticing around
the shop now I'm like okay what you
doing here your record is crazy yeah
they like what you doing what you got
going you need to get about it like that
so I sat in the um I pulled up one
morning sitting in the car with I got
now my boy then we seen that we seen
that Chopper I sitting the cop BB now
with the name BB we standing cover BB on
God Santa Claus now I'm sitting there
rolling up got down in the train and
Trans Am and God damn great car yeah
that [__] he's in right there oh
no yeah
he's like uh here no you got to go right
there so she I mean he taught me in one
of them back I emailed one of them back
and and those [__] they're saying today
they put me on the plane that same day
I was in here in New York is how you
ended up doing the United Masters
situation
no I didn't on the United Methodist is
what you came along with with
before that time that was in there
before that day because you already
getting distro through them yeah I'm
already my my already was through them
from like 2020 October right you know
what I'm saying so
I well now they were going crazy the
funny thing about it I was waiting on
United Master to hit me up because they
had the record you feel right right they
distributed yeah they distributed so I
was waiting on them to hit me up man
they were like they hit me up like a
like a week a week before a week before
this this car you feel me and I had
talked to somebody but then I was like I
knew what I was going to do
but still I'm like [__] I need to go see
what the options is right you feel me so
I ain't telling them there but I went
through all the option worked out in my
favor and then at the end of the options
I seen all the moving around David and
then I ain't no running into the Steve
stop and then you got now we
we chopped and she ate dinner a couple
nights and [__] in the rooms [__]
I'm like I talked to the team and [__]
I'm like all right
if they in one thing if you showed again
they got confidence so [__] I say
until I find my team or if I'm gonna
rock with them I'm gonna see can they
you know what I'm saying
can they do this [__] for me you know
what I'm saying like what are we doing
like that like boom so [__] went on with
the move
come on with the move bro [__] I'm
watching this [__] go crazy I'm sleeping
in every every car I'm going to sleep in
waking up new numbers yeah waking you up
your [__] on the radio right that Troy
Marshall hits [__]
hey where you go today
you're on the radio listen let's go to
sleep here it was so yeah they [__]
in my sleep to my song you feel me I'm
like this [__] crazy bro you ran down
the road three four times before you
could do your destination
that's crazy I mean you look man that's
when you when you catch a record like
that I mean you're close to going number
one in urban so once let's go get to the
point where you're going in the cities
you're just gonna hear your record all
day
it's not a bad I mean you know
just think about from coming from a
mechanic shop a few months ago
it's kind of crazy uh what was your
childhood like like how did you grow up
like because obviously small area in
Mississippi where you're playing sports
where you like what were you into when
you were a kid man
I'm gonna be real man I want an
interesting nothing but the streets I'm
gonna be real
and then it got to the point where their
life got so bored
and it's so quick like before seven I
ain't seen so much
in the streets like before seven four
seven Jesus
before seven I probably seen more than
every 16 year old ever see right right
and got so tied up and
she Mama tied up
and she really falling off you see what
I'm saying like I'm watching the game
like I ain't seen like she just fell in
love and watching it and watching this
[__] from the lifestyle they go from
Jordans every week to God damn you ain't
getting this [__] today or you're from
you know what I'm saying girlfriend
sharing me you know you go from eating
in the insurance and you know you know
you're watching this [__] going down
here to eat nothing sandwiches and
sardines and and noodles and got them
you know Hot Dog Smoke sizes and ham and
cheese and you know what I'm saying you
know what I'm saying you got all kind of
[__] they would you know you're about
just at home like [__] kind of started
to go left in terms of the money yeah
life it was oh you're watching this [__]
you're going from all this [__] eating
out and moving around here like I like I
say all that you're going from stuck in
the house can't move stuck in the
project you know what I'm saying you
can't move you're stuck in the name of a
one way in one way out and then you you
got to be in for the street lights and
you can't go outside the territory like
you know what I'm saying she's just an
apartment you can't go outside this
whatever you're gonna do all day from
then you can't stay in the house so you
gotta go hang out you gotta go outside
and you can't be around your porch right
you got to go everywhere out here but
around here where you at but when the
street lights come on you got to go home
when you see the first screen like you
gotta be home
you stay I passed out on the street like
this so you know hey are you gonna get
punished for that uh what inspired you
was it someone in your family was it
like to start rapping so early you say
you start rapping at five right
yeah I mean that's pretty crazy I mean
like what was the inspiration with
behind just wanting to get involved in
music in the first place
we we might I'm gonna say my
my perspective of it is is uh
when we I'm gonna say my respect
what got me in the music was Ryan and we
would go down the road we're going to
interstate going to you know see the
city with me a woman [__]
um
no she was a Beyonce your mom she would
be unsafe she was Beyonce
what do you mean by that
she she was Beyonce God damn it like
every day we listen to Beyonce again
okay okay so your mom was bumping the
[__] out of Beyonce and she you couldn't
tell her she wouldn't be anything okay
okay
I get so tired of hearing this [__] I
ain't gonna laugh but too much Beyonce
invitation like but growing up right
growing up man [__] you saying this is
growing up
he's before seven now oh it is
so we traveling and [__] and
and Beyonce I was on the radio or not
I'm always
pushing this [__] off you know what I'm
saying all right we're going down the
road
I'm screaming stopping the car man I
ain't trying to hear this [__] like and
we end up finding me some music
so she wouldn't let me you know at the
time you know [__] we were listening she
was listening to Yo Gotti
female female rapper so she oh male rap
away yo got in but Beyonce but no
and she prayed Yo Gotti when Beyonce
wasn't playing
so they said I go Yo Gotti yeah that's
how I can end up getting my my time in
because I ain't wanna hear that [__] so
I can listen to that [__] and she she
said um the first thing she said she
said I was in that [__] trying
to I was in that big reaching I probably
like she said about four five I was in
that baby saying pure cocaine and
writing that [__] down to what I
can
remember that [__] and and she
I made my first song and I was like 87.
yeah so have you met Yo Gotti yet
hey man yo gotta here I'm gonna be real
I ain't really into meeting people
though
I I mean why not Yo Gotti that'd be kind
of cool if you could explain that to him
in person like hey bro you know when I
was five years old it was because my
mama made me listen to that that was the
only choice I had you feel right you
should have made if she would have cut
on anything yet but Beyonce you would
have been into it I'd have been okay you
would have been whatever it was as long
as it wasn't Beyonce yeah so it was like
I ain't I ain't gonna say like [__] that
was my I ain't doing nothing like that
that was just the only access of music I
had to at that point right and it went
from there to growing up that was all
you had in the hood like when nobody you
can't get no music through Mississippi
right they ain't gonna let you you feel
me I don't even know how he did it to be
real he had to go through people in
Mississippi because I don't see him just
pushing music through Mississippi you
can't just push me through Mississippi
you got to know people there like it
ain't no just getting it through there
so he had to Bootleg and [__] everywhere
in the hood that's all you seen is
seeing one see him two cm3 and you
listen to everybody in the hood just
bumping this [__] you feel me so [__]
just go through it right there you know
just catching on as I made it down to
Mississippi when I'm six years old like
she able to comprehend what's going on
and [__] this you know what I'm saying
like it just was
like what it was you and your mama on
the road a lot you said yeah like from
all the day all the time we never sit
down until seven what was she ubering or
something what's going on ain't doing no
Uber we don't even play like that I'm
just I don't know
and I was gonna let y'all do that
um what's up y'all bootleg Kev here man
got to tell you about our new sponsors
at King Palm baby got a shout out to
them and we're welcoming him into the
new family man of course uh we treat all
of our partners at the bootle cat
podcast like family shout out to King
Palm man if y'all don't know about King
Palm they are the leaders in the smoking
industry when it comes to their
tobacco-free blunt wraps no nicotine no
tobacco just good old leaves all right
yeah that's right um and look their
product that I love are these right here
now these right here are the pre-rolled
tips you just stuff them with your your
herb your cannabi that you get from a
Hardin and uh they got these terpene and
flu infused uh tips now what they are is
you put your wheat in there all right
you hit the [__] little pinch on that
thing and you could just burst the
flavor now these are the red reins which
is like an energy drink flavor obviously
they got the Strawberry Shortcake which
is also gas now this is what's dope too
there's just so many lines of these
rolls uh shout out to the leaf tubes you
can get these blueberry these big blue
grape Fusion joints so much you can get
man so many products uh check out your
local 7-Eleven your local smoke shop all
that but you could also go to
kingpom.com right now and get everything
online delivered right to your door for
half off 50 off if you use that promo
code bootleg that's right shout out to
King Palm man we're talking about
essential smoking uh when it comes to
like just getting that Clean Smoke it's
not too harsh or organic you ain't
putting nothing crazy in your lungs you
know what I'm saying shout out to King
pong no tobacco no nicotine just
straight look and I gotta shout them out
too because
can we take just take a a good look at
this
you know we got multiple sized King Palm
hitters over here
I think right there is like a goddamn
Jesus
that's a [__] boy right there you
know what I mean shout out to King Palm
that's a king pong Leaf right there
stuff with some fire some fire all right
so look right now you're going to want
to go to uh kingpom.com uh use that
promo code bootleg get half off whatever
you need smoking accessories Leafs some
of these awesome uh pre-rolls that they
have that you just stuff your stuff in
stuff your stuff in you know what I mean
um kingpom.com 7-Eleven your local smoke
shop all that make sure you follow them
online at King Palm and check them out
speaking of stuff that you're stuffing
shout out to my bookie man my bookie you
already know mybookie.ag I'm riding with
the Phoenix Suns God damn it them Sons
going all the way uh if you are like me
and you like to uh you know put a
friendly wager on some sports
which I do a lot I've been using my
bookie for about 10 years now uh you can
go do the same thing right now now this
is what's dope about my book you go to
mybookie.ag it's the online sports book
not only is it an online sports book
they got the Blackjack they got the
whole Casino situation craps roulette
whatever you're into you could play it
right at mybookie.ag and if you use the
promo code bootleg when you sign up
bootleg you'll see it down below
[Music]
when you sign up you'll get that first
deposit bonus now get a new account
mybookie.ag when you sign up bootleg is
the promo code first deposit bonus up to
a thousand dollars you put in money they
give you money it's that simple all
right there's so many ways you can win
money of course they got NHL right now
the playoffs are happening in hockey if
you're from [__] Canada and you care
about a terrible boring sport also
basketball NBA playoffs are booming
right now put all the money on the
future for the sunset with a
championship thank me later I got Sons
versus Celtics in the uh finals also
baseball
another atrociously boring sport but a
great sport to gamble on all right so
what you're going to want to do go to
mybookie.ag use that promo code bootleg
right now and get uh your first deposit
bonus
unlocked speaking of unlocked
unlock your [__]
go to bluetooth.com right now
it is summertime if you're dealing with
elect erectile dysfunction Ed if you
will maybe you got stress at work
maybe you're tired of looking at the
same chick
maybe you just need a little pep in your
step
um you need to get on that blue too man
you don't need to do anything but it'd
be nice to have the option to so go to
bluetooth.com right now
use the promo code bootleg and get the
first month supply of Bluetooth for free
what is Bluetooth
well Bluetooth is a chewable gets
delivered to your door in a discrete
package no doctor's appointments no
doctor's visits
and uh it has the same active ingredient
as Viagra
and Cialis
so we're talking about getting your dick
hard here in case that went over your
head you know it won't go over your head
once you take it I promise you that all
right Bluetooth also is uh incredible
because not only does it come in the
blue chewable flavor with the same
active ingredient as vibrancy house but
it also has a mint chewable flavor which
is the same active ingredient as Levitra
all right all this if you're questioning
I don't know I don't want to spend no
money on does this [__] work look yes it
works and you don't have to spend money
if you use the promo code bootleg at
bluetooth.com because it's going to get
delivered right to your house they're
going to give you a month's supply for
free you just got to pay five dollars
shipping that's it the bluetooth's come
into your house no awkward doctor's
appointments
no awkward doctor's visits it's all
online
bluetooth.com thank me later thank me
later let's get back to the interview
now you think of Mississippi obviously
there's been some some successful
artists out of Mississippi shout out to
Ray schremmer shout out to David Banner
uh who else am I missing
who else from Mississippi is I mean
obviously yourself big crit is Chris the
one yeah Chris one of my favorite
rappers ever I don't know why I didn't
say him he got another hood rappers
though we don't really just focus on
really just going too crazy most people
just we just want to get on the stage
one time and then go back to the house
we ain't really
focusing on being the the world's
largest artist you know right because we
we focus on another we focus on what
other things in life you know what I'm
saying we got other things to tend to
besides you know a phone you know what
I'm saying we can't focus on the phone
down there you get you look in your
phone too long down there you're gonna
end up gone you see what I'm saying you
can't be on your phone no so this ad is
you ain't no you ain't no no phones if
you could do anything obviously let's
say you having a crazy career in hip-hop
you put yourself in a financially
amazing position to just do what you
want outside of music what would you
want to do
um
outside of music
you take music away from me
dude we're gonna be [__] up no I'm
saying like let's say like 10 years from
now you're going a crazy run you got
money to do whatever you want you could
travel you could open up a business
rebuild [__] engines I don't know
what what would you want to do besides I
don't I don't never see the world
already is you see what I'm saying the
world yeah so I don't get into
businesses in in this and they and they
I don't do all that I ain't with that
because one thing for sure I can only
Prosper you feel me I know I can only
Prosper so high in it so I don't even
waste my time because I'm a real Bulldog
and when I can't get what I want I tear
[__] up so that's why I don't get into
[__] and I stay to myself you feeling
that way I don't do it like because I
know you get a business I don't watch it
you you grind up you do everything do
you do you got all the tools you need to
do the job
all the money in the world they can't
get you to where you want to go
you feel me the money in the world can't
get you where you want to go it it ain't
it ain't gonna do it it's it's already
set up bro you see me
I understand that
so therefore I know one thing in
Mississippi
the word can't do what we do you feel me
so like I told you I was before they got
there this interview like they they
still doing it you feel me so I gotta go
deal with that at home you feel me the
racist [__] in Mississippi yeah you feel
me but
I understand in life that they're just
not Mississippi you feel me right you
know what I'm saying yeah so I take what
I've been taught and I take it with me
everywhere I never forget that because
at the end of the day I know you feel me
I ain't getting into that I don't want
to prosper and I ain't trying to be
nothing great I'm gonna just drop these
singers in these music you know what I'm
saying like I told you I wanted to just
get a music to the world and stay at the
shop you feel me so they won't be mad at
me but they want me to go do a couple
shows and show my face to the world a
little bit I'm gonna go pay my dues and
then I'm going back to the shop you feel
me but I ain't gonna be out here trying
to take over this industry and none of
that you know what I'm saying I don't
want to be no president I ain't trying
to do nothing I ain't gonna do nothing
spectacular nothing out the way
so you you say for you you're just like
kind of you're just happy to be able to
I'm happy to be alive fair enough
would you give me a like a if you could
do a pain pictures remix who would you
put on it or is that in the works it
feels like the type of record that a
remix should should be coming
I just told you I ain't going I can't do
no linking man I I say man listen I
dropped I'm dropped another verse on
there and I just keep telling my story
and they bite my story they bite my
story or they can keep following you
know what they want to follow you know
or they can come see the real deal you
know what's coming next um Troy was just
telling me got a crazy new song that's
on the way yeah like crazy agenda Plan B
it's going crazy everywhere like on my
YouTube YouTube like 1 30. he got like
130k on YouTube right now going up it's
not doing consistent numbers I haven't
heard it yet it's Plan B about
a plan B A Plan B pill or Plan B in life
a Plan B pill it was riding the time
that they had by the way both can be
true a Plan B pill is also a plan B in
life
it is
yeah I should get out of jail card right
there
yeah yeah you're right how many plan B's
have you bought over the years man
[__] I can't count I ain't gonna lie
they need to sponsor me that's why I
made the song
and why I made this song I hear you man
I've been trying to get sponsorships all
my life
[Laughter]
yeah yeah we need all that the trip to
the like the trip to like CVS or
Walgreens at like 2 30 in the morning
though to get the plan B is like very
like when you're checking out and the
guy at the registers looking at you nah
just just imagine this though
you know you got 72 hours you got 72
hours all right look I don't you don't
want to risk it
you you forgetting them 72 hours and my
stuff closed at nine hmm
you see what I'm saying Walgreen
clothing at nine right you go through
the whole day you forget to grab three
days later
hey look 850 and you 20 minutes away
like technically I got 20 more minutes
according to the package according to
the instructions
you don't have any children
no I'll tell you I ain't salute to plan
B man eight yeah shout out to plan B
okay
get up early as soon as that [__] opens
I can't complain man do you have to
watch the girl take the plan b
I trust I trust until you make me not
trust you know but here you go here's
the water and then just sit there hell
no
they're just crazy you know what I'm
saying they play crazy but they got
sense oh God all alone are they getting
a little more crazier now that you're
getting a lot more famous
I don't put myself around crazy females
well I hate I mean
every woman is crazy
no I ain't gonna say look how you right
you're right you're right you're right
hey all women little kid you right from
[__] they be coming from you know my
drink I keep my my random Walmart nah my
gym ain't coming from Rand from from
Walmart my gen coming from home I got I
got a couple of gents I'm always keep
and they're gonna stay like that you
feel me until I you know what I'm saying
what's your what would you say is your
type like if you had to like give me a
famous person that would kind of line up
with you what your type is
but everybody crazy as hell what's your
type hey man
hey man yeah Ray Sherman man he from
Mississippi baby girl my BG hey I'll
take you off from my choice of business
you ain't gonna want them what does that
mean
how do you know what I like sir well
yeah I tell you that fool hey bro we
ain't got that many choices down there
look they getting they starting to look
good in that though I ain't gonna let it
look good now well now that you are are
exploring the rest of the country
uh your options are opening up the type
of women that you have access to ah
listen man don't you I just told you I
don't deal with craziness man yeah but
if you're you're in L.A right now right
you if you you're in L.A there's some of
the most beautiful women in the world
are here
yeah but I can't I ain't tell you bro
I'd rather just I'm saying wait I'm
gonna I'm on business trip when I'm
working on working right now when I'm
when I'm having fun I'm having fun I
ain't got no time cause if I get a bad
joke with me right now I get distracted
you see this is fair you know I I'm I'm
all right once I get them around
everybody else is nothing to me so as I
get them I'm busy it's over with you my
words you're the type of person if you
hit with a girl you're fully just dived
in yeah it's always yeah I got a friend
named Cyrus who's like that he's old I
gotta I'm I'm it's over with is it
little winner I'm talking about when I'm
with them
off
uh
hey it depends
well that might answer sometime but I'm
saying that nine times out of ten don't
call me you know who I'm with you feel
me would you say you're a faithful guy
if you're with a girl
I'm favored to what we got going yeah
I'm favored to what we got going I like
that faithful to the understanding
yeah yeah all that you know what I'm
saying I'm just she know we ain't I
don't get too far in it in this side of
that I just let them know you know we be
cool I like having good female friends
you know what I'm saying okay you came
in here and you pronounced the word
music music and I've only heard people
from Memphis say that way whether it's
gorilla or Dolph or key Glock everybody
says music okay is this for Mississippi
or is this from Tennessee who can claim
the accent properly man where did it
originate
man the whole this whole this us this us
Mississippi I say Memphis should be
Mississippi I don't think they should be
Tennessee it's me
I think that should be Mississippi
because that's the only place I feel
like Memphis
was made was made for us to get it for
the slaves to get a little freedom
Memphis was made yeah because like I'm
gonna tell you growing up for me Memphis
is with the forest we could go okay how
far is that from where you're from like
30 like 30 30 or 40 minutes oh that's
not far at all right so you get up there
and you see all these you see the mall
you see the light the Grizzlies you see
the Grizzlies yeah you see all this [__]
and then you go back to the trenches
right you see what I'm saying but as far
as you get to see from there you see
what I'm saying so I always my dream was
like why in the world everybody else got
all this stuff why come Mississippi
ain't got no national football team why
we ain't got no national basketball team
so I think it ain't that it ain't dead I
don't like other places it's dead I grew
to to you know what I'm saying stand up
for with all I got you feeling I grew to
do with that other stuff you know what
I'm saying so I'm good with not having
to go to places and go nowhere you see I
can't go there I ain't the type of
person to bully you into not going to go
in there he said I can't go I'm okay
with not going there I'm cool you feel
me right because it's the whole world
down here that they didn't forget about
it you feel what I'm saying so
while y'all doing it
I'm gonna be attending to this somehow
some way you feel me because I know one
thing it was the most richest state in
the world at one time Mississippi was
you can look it up I don't I look you
know more than me you can look it up man
I've never been every every day you walk
outside you win
it's closed bro you know what I'm saying
I hope so it's a felony otherwise or it
might be a mystery or eventually it'll
be a felony right right so it's a felony
and with all your clothes coming from
China
see where they getting it from
Mississippi yeah I am
oh wait
you ever seen a cotton field
okay yes of course on the phone or in
person
I've never seen one in person
man see what I'm saying
I don't think we have those on the west
coast you know what I'm saying we got
like strawberry fields and like
lettuce and avocados like do you like
guacamole hell no what the [__] what do
you eat no bro
you don't like guacamole but it isn't we
that's what I'm telling you we live on a
whole nother world I got Chipotle in
Mississippi none of that you don't have
Chipotle in Mississippi do we go to
Chipotle
that's [__] crazy
it's not Mississippi fool
hey hey so what bro I'm gonna tell you
then bro look bro listen bro the Delta
is Mississippi bro the other [__] is
just uh Outlet okay this is how we can
it's how we can see other [__]
okay this the only way is to go to South
Haven go get some clothes South Haven's
in Mississippi South Haven Mississippi
okay so it is in Mississippi I didn't
never go to Jackson until I'm 13 14 and
that's the big six that's two hours from
my house but I've never been to Jackson
That's the biggest city in Mississippi
that's the capital right I've never been
there until I'm 13 14. but you've been
to Memphis which is probably a better
place to go right I went to Memphis I
went Closer To Home Fayetteville
Tennessee
well yeah I'm in that range
of Memphis Mississippi how's Nashville
heavy I heard Nashville survive I [__]
on that video it's a lot of money out
there Young Bucks there
yeah uh huh who else is from Nashville
jelly roll a lot of dope guys from
Nashville uh Focus Starlito Starlito is
a legend yeah shout out to Starlito yeah
yeah probably haven't done it for sure I
was gonna say him and Don Trip they put
out that how about that damn I forgot
about Don Trip I'm still bro you know
them boys go crazy back in the day but
they probably got some new [__] in there
but I haven't really just listened to
music since I started doing music so
you're just focused on creating the best
[__] you can every day what's up guys
hey uh if you are watching this and it's
April 20th 4 20
I'm gonna be hanging out at hardean
today
that's right put the flyer up The Rock
I'll be at hardeen um hanging out all
day today
um the craziest most just luxurious
illest dispensary in the world located
right in Los Vegas Nevada now Hardy in
Las Vegas they are our family they'd
sponsor the podcast I love those guys
dearly and when I say that it is the
best place I've ever walked into to buy
premium cannabis I'm not lying best
customer service
best bud tenders best bud
to put in your King Palm
and uh just overall man just a great
experience um so what you all need to do
is go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas follow him on the
gram we got a lot of dope stuff in the
works they actually just opened a a fire
podcast studio so we're going to be
doing a lot of content in Vegas
live from Hardin they also just dropped
a [__] tennis shoe with Fila they got
dope flag gear
um man premium cannabis the best
selection
culture
sniff you walk in that man listen they
got I'm not even lying to y'all Harding
has their own signature scent and it
smells good I keep a bottle of it in my
car literally maybe twice a day I spray
get that hard eating with smells amazing
so look make sure you go to hardine uh
if you're in Vegas get in that Uber get
in that cab as soon as you touch down
say take me to Harding the taxi drivers
the Ubi drivers they know exactly where
it is because it's the hottest spot in
Vegas they go take you straight there
you're gonna tell them I sent you
they're going to get you situated real
nicely all right Harding underscore Las
Vegas go show them some love go to
hardinglasvegas.com gotta give a shout
out to our oh geez my dogs that Odd
Socks baby they've been [__] with us
from day one
um and they've been dropping so many
crazy dope new like socks you know first
of all can we talk about Beavis and
Butthead they just dropped the Beavis
and Butt-head socks and draws let's take
a check this is a nice little peek at
the Beavis and Butthead
drawskis bro
oh
come on man
they also just dropped Coca-Cola we got
Scarface we got Reese's we got the big
[__] Lebowski so many dope socks the
most comfortable socks in the world the
most comfortable underwear in the world
and check this out right now you can get
20 off that's 20 off at checkout
at oddsoxofficial.com using the promo
code bootleg so go right now
otsoxofficial.com my first uh suggestion
would be get you a pair or a pack of the
Odd Socks Basics the black and the
whites those are my go-to's and then you
gotta [__] with some of these Big
Lebowski socks and they just got
Coca-Cola
they got the Scarface boys like what are
we talking about man what are you
waiting on they are the most comfortable
socks in the world
um so if you're not wearing Odd Socks
you're just cheating yourself you know
what I mean you're really cheating
yourself
they got [__] South Park
come on bruh what are we talking about
go to oddsocksofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg save 20 off at
checkout on the most comfortable socks
in the world or don't and keep torturing
yourself with those shitty socks you're
wearing right now
be a damn shame anyway let's get back to
the interview
uh is there an album coming
most different how many songs you got
done what 21 21 it's not a bad number
it'll be a [__] two albums really
let's do a ten joints and then 11 later
I'm gonna give him 21. right
I'll be 21 this year
so now we know how old you are damn
21.
[Applause]
I kind of figured that out when he was
like I learned
straight cocaine when I was [__] six
or seven I was like
everybody said look dye you never talk
about the streets on it on these
internet you know what I'm saying
rappers this is why you never do it you
feel me and this is why I only go to
interviews you know what I'm saying and
when you get interrogated don't even
talk you feel me because they tricky
well I'm not trying to feel me It's
Tricky do you think you see what I'm
saying do you think do you think I gotta
be quiet did I just trick you just go in
there and shut up are you saying I
tricked you you got to I didn't know you
can talk look you didn't say hey and you
said for who I'm gonna tell you this I
happen you ain't trying to snitch you
just end up snitching you see what I'm
saying oh you're saying like in a
different situation if you're talking
about what happened you might [__] a
lot of [__] up this is the difference is
waiting I'm talking about my life that's
why I don't rap about nothing else I
read about my life good you know what
I'm saying that will happen
this exactly what happened every time
everybody just shut up do you think
that's what happened with Gunner he just
wouldn't stop they were just heaven with
every snitch
uh so albums on the way uh plan B's out
now hopefully he won't be buying any
more plan B's for a while uh yeah I am
be going crazy like that man I'm done
with that [__] I can't take no more Rich
no more you know it's over with it's
over with because they ain't gonna they
ain't gonna do it like if they was they
ain't gonna be too quick to um took a
pop the pill yeah they're gonna win
they're winning they're gonna have your
Superstar Pride for sure but they're
running around yeah I try to stay I try
to stay you know what I'm saying let
them know who I am
you know what I'm saying so a little bit
you know what I'm saying they'd be like
no I don't want hit baby
dude throw it off
take a b a peek behind the curtain a
little bit yeah let them do a little bit
Yeah because I know once the kid gear I
would be a whole different person I'm
already mean
you know I'm gonna be real thrilled off
by them you know what I'm saying yo you
waited too long your haircut is this
technically a shag
um I'm gonna be real
I really I don't know what to call I
never I never even I think it's a shag I
think so I think I think I know um my
uncle really just did it I still ain't
even never even
yeah
he had something like that he had
something like this but the thing about
it is I um uh I seen I seen a different
haircut I ain't see there's no when he
did it the first time like the video
that was the first time he had just cut
it like the same day like so
I ain't know what he was doing before I
sat down my hair was like everywhere oh
my God is your uncle your Barber yeah he
get out the plane and I mean I got to go
he lands and he's cutting you up yeah
yeah I gotta get that I ain't never sat
down I gotta tell you I don't even know
what's on my head this is he had this
haircut and he just put it on my head
because he said his Superstar haircut
and he said I'm gonna give you you said
you a superstar but I'm gonna give you
your own haircut I like that and then he
couldn't and I like the way it was like
it would like you feed me with like it
was like boom it went it went like
dropping like it is dropping them you
see how it dropping him right now nah I
like to have wolves you need to go
like
uh for somebody who used to work at a
car shop that builds engines what's your
dream car
you know I ain't no mechanic for real
man I've just seen the I'm a Bentley guy
you want a Bentley yeah I won't be in
the guy man I ain't doing too much
working on you don't want no hot rod
man no I ain't doing all that I just did
all that cause I had two man you was
getting paid
no
I wouldn't even
the money never been me I knew I would
be your rich kid it would never worry
about money with me I always did it off
of I want to work and learn I never work
for money if you paid me to do it I'm
probably not gonna do it you said I'm
gonna pay you to do it I ain't probably
ain't gonna do it
like period money never been because I
walk up and ask me something they say
here you go so I never really needed
money right
money was my least concern ever it's
still my least concern I don't even look
at money like I don't look at no
receipts listen man you you should be on
top of your [__] uh I think that's what
is stressful I think it's stressful even
to even think about something that you
don't have to sometimes
when you don't look at [__] people can
take advantage of your finances bro this
is yeah but when you start thinking
about it it's like when you start
looking into stuff well listen you're 20
years old right right that's what I'm
saying I ain't about 30 35 40. no no no
no people use just like this I always
looked at it like this bro
all right you get Troy I I'm gonna read
that you know when he was my age you
know how many kids you have yeah
Troy how many children are already at
20. was it zero or was it seven
it was just Sylvan Marshall okay look
but you got all these people it's
already made it you know what I'm saying
past this stage so listen when people in
this stage of life you gotta think about
it
these people
are what you call you know what I'm
saying
the people that need to learn you feel
me they need to learn these people like
when we was at you was at the stage I
mean we need to learn when I was 20 I
had a four-year-old uh see
it was different I'm just saying like it
take this time I take this time to learn
just like everybody else in their time
should learn and you let the OG's
you don't do work for money you just
take the knowledge you see what I'm
saying
now when you get in the position I'm in
when you surpass you can received a lot
of knowledge and you don't received a
lot of stuff you did a lot of stuff now
you now you're going into
outputting everything you didn't learn
so now it's like
you need to not worry so much about the
money just worry about when I go outside
am I going to be able to do what I want
to do um
well there you have it uh any idea when
the album's dropping
soon summertime yeah I'm gonna go around
I'm gonna go around July okay summertime
around July do we have a name yet
uh seven seven
cause you're lucky
they're my favorite number I always had
number seven and everything I did it's a
lucky number you know when you go to
Vegas and you hit the slot machine and
once it gets all sevens you win money
all right you're not old enough to
gamble yet I've never been a gambler
neither
when you turn 21 don't they got casinos
all over Mississippi
yeah that's the thing where's all we got
people fly in take our money and they
leave us they come in do the show take
out money they leave but they're going
wait wait wait wait you know who didn't
do that though you know who was living
in Mississippi for a while I'm not sure
if he's still but young blue was living
there for a minute you see what I'm
saying like he went there that's where
he kind of put his roots down and was in
Mississippi
well guess what I didn't know that we
didn't know that he had a restaurant in
Jackson Jackson in in the Delta is a
little different it's like Jackson is
like the city
now when I go to Jackson it's like the
city for me it's like the big city yeah
he liked the city for me
you guys don't even have a Chipotle
where you're from
well hey we got Walmart Dollar General
hey how crazy is the Walmart in
Mississippi that [__] got to be maggot
you know it oh my that's all they got
just [__] white trash Galore
uh no It's gotta be crazy is your is
your Walmart 24 hours
oh
did it used to be 24 hours it used to be
after cover you know everything over
with yo that 24-hour Walmart two three
in the morning that was different
different but we're going in just hang
out people watch steal ride the carts we
don't do no students I definitely have
shoplifted at the Walmart I'll be too
scared to steal you ever ride the
handicap card still around
oh yeah we did it yeah of course what
else are you gonna do with two in the
morning at Walmart because most of the
people I'm assuming
most of the people in Mississippi who
are at a Walmart at two in the morning
Who quote unquote need a handicap
scooter I'll probably be just obese and
fat and lazy
uh
uh that way they don't come down there
talking like that
you come down there talking like that
you want to
you a bad [__] just a big old
fat dude with the fupa
right there he got heat he's definitely
got the Maga hat on
oh well I'll tell you that look it's
that boy you get to talking like that
down there you a bad [__] he was
a bad [__] so I haven't been
look
you just said the f word what did I say
fupa
what's the f word well
what fupa
yeah that's a different word down there
that's different bro like bro I'm
telling you gonna see somebody go from
these beads to running these he look
like he's running these small looking
like Zion Williams just
all right you looking inside I haven't
seen 20 of them [__]
just like okay we got one on the screen
now you feel me boy you come down there
be ain't no telling what you gonna see
so you would say fat is is a triggering
word for Mississippi folks man you got
me throw it already man I'm scared of
you right now hey look I ain't got
nothing to do with this [__]
hear me manifold don't play
[Music]
you ain't gonna play down now
I don't care is it like that is you know
y'all understand it's ugly people
driving a lot of respect man you feel me
it's we based off respecting loyalty
like
this was going on Donna it's Moore's in
principles have you ever linked up with
uh any of the other guys from from
Mississippi like Creator bro that's how
we bro let's just I'm gonna just say
this is how we use bro we don't do all
that Lincoln no linking we don't do all
of it with all that bro if we link up we
bumped into each other at the store and
we left the store and we went chilled
and we were dealt we had just bumped
into each other and we were with each
other the rest of the time when we leave
each other we probably ain't gonna see
each other another three months
um
when you making calls and moving around
shit's gonna go down it ain't no pulling
up right [__] finna go down you get to
seeing [__] moving you need to move out
the way and ladies and gentlemen
this is the reason why I will be
visiting Mississippi ASAP the next time
you have a show we got to come and hang
out we're gonna go to Walmart
wow
hey I'm gonna bring a bag of operations
grab me some t-shirt drives and socks
let's go kick it at Walmart at two in
the morning man see what happens yeah ah
you go kick it I'm straight uh anyway
look appreciate you man the album's
coming out in July hopefully yeah
july-ish plan B's out paint pictures is
out
no remix on the way no I can't do no
remixes man I'm gonna be real until I
until I find I'm gonna say [__] if I if
I find you know be cool with somebody
but I ain't just gonna be linking up
just off a [__] word because if it
ain't think he gonna [__] with me today
and then not tomorrow
you need to take that song Down
oh [__]
take it down I don't want it on no
platform like if I don't [__] with you
this song ain't gonna be on no platform
There It Is Well uh go run up uh the new
record and that's what we got to do
because I don't [__] with people
therefore we gotta do good music Plan B
we gotta do good music why because I
don't got nobody no I don't [__] with
people whoever makes Plan B should give
you a sponsorship you know whatever
company that is at CVS and Walmart
that'd be nice you're gonna say that
though I just be talking a lot of [__]
it wouldn't be it would be you know nah
I'm gonna be real bro like I told you I
just I just wanna you know what I'm
saying do my thing go back home and
chill out I ain't into I talk about this
[__] big game you know but that ain't
gonna do too much
I actually do too much man well I
appreciate you pulling up man no no
spawns and [__] they keep that [__] I
just wanna Superstar Pride leave man
you're doing a good job man
congratulations appreciate you coming
through bro appreciate it yes sir